gonna how is Europe doing in terms of
the Digital Agenda not good enough and
that's good because if this was the best
we could do it would be quite hopeless
and we can do a lot better on fibre
rather well in a number of countries but
still not good enough regarding a mobile
broadband but not at all as good as it
should be and for me these two things
are very closely linked together because
the development of the new services are
very much dependent on the development
of the mobile broadband while the fixed
lives the fiber we provide the stability
for all the different service you want
to do so they are very closely connected
but we are not transforming enough we're
not changing enough and we need to do
that and I think the only key to that is
that we must be much better on securing
that we have the fiber connections and
the coverage that we need to have
because that is a precondition for the
development of the mobile service beat
wifey or be it mobile broadband or
whatever because people are already
talking about 5g that's coming along at
a fast pace how do you see that
impacting on fibre I think 5g will mean
an acceleration of the traffic because
it will be an acceleration of all the
new services you can have driver
vehicles without a driver which requires
a lot of traffic in the net in the fixed
left as well as under indifferent mobile
applications and you can have a medical
services you will have all this machine
to machine and well the internet of
everything and the internet of
everything will require everything fiber
and mobile broadband and my main
messages never fall into the trap that
the mobile broadband is another thing
that the fixed and the fix is another
thing the limo Bob they are closely
dependent on each other not only for
their basic
and from the mental traffic but also for
the development of the services
presuming that we eventually get this
right and we all move forward in Europe
how do you see the relationship between
the ICT industry and European business
developing what are going to be the
benefit so my view is that we will talk
about ICT in the future as we today are
talking about electricity as a very
normal phenomenal I mean it is some
decades ago when we looked upon the ICT
people as people in white coats being a
rather mysterious and in a special
Department in the company or etc now it
is distributed and among us all but we
still tend to talk about the digital
sector in the next 10 years to come we
will have no digital sector because our
society will be based on the digital
technologies as electricity has been for
quite a while so I think we are which is
a paradoxical thing we are entering
phase of normalization while the
internet and the very managing
applications will form the structure of
our economy and society and that means
that we need to be in the lead in this
development because otherwise we will
not be in the lead of the economical
development well let's hope we can get
into that lead position thank you very
much for joining us and giving us
insight into what you feel the issues
are thank you very much